- [Voiceover] You're at a
florist store and you're
interested in buying some
type of a potted flower.
And you ask the florist, "What
type of flowers do you sell?"
And he says, "Well we sell
four types of flowers, we sell
"roses, tulips, sunflowers, and lilies."
And you say, "What type of
pots could I put them in?"
And he says, "Well you could
pick any flower, and then you
"could pick any of our three
pots, we have brown pots,
"we have yellow pots,
and we have green pots."
So, the question that I ask to you is,
how many types of, I guess,
flower and pots put together can
you walk out of this florist store with?
For example, you could get
a rose and a brown pot,
you could get a rose and a green pot.
Or you could get a yellow pot
that has a sunflower in it.
Or a yellow pot that has a lily in it.
So, how many scenarios could you walk out
of that store with?
And like always, I'll encourage
you to pause the video
and try to figure it out on your own.
Let's think through it.
I'll just write the first
letters, just to visualize
or just so I don't have
to write down everything.
So, you could have a brown pot,
you could have a yellow pot,
or you could have a green pot.
You difinitely have to pick a
pot, so you're going to have
one of those.
And then for each of these
three, there's four possible
flowers you could have.
You could have a rose with the brown pot,
you could have a rose with the yellow pot,
you could have a rose with the green pot.
You could have a tulip with the brown pot,
a tulip with the yellow pot,
a tulip with the green pot.
You could have a sunflower
with each of the three pots,
or you could have a
lily with the brown pot,
a lily with the yellow pot,
and a lily with a green pot.
So, how many scenarios
are we talking about?
Well, we had three pots, so
we have three pots right over
here, and we have four possible
flowers to put in the pots,
and so we see that we have
four possible flowers for each
of the three pots.
It's going to be three times
four possibilites, or 12.
You see them right over here.
This is brown with rose, brown with tulip,
brown with sunflower, brown with lily.
Yellow with rose, yellow with
tulip, yellow with sunflower,
yellow with lily.
So, if we count these, one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve.
Twelve possible pot, flower scenarios
to walk out of that florist store with.